[Musique]
on va parler avec notre ca ce soit aux
insee dodier bonsoir robert dutton beaux
soirs alors constat sévère du
commissaire au développement durable du
québec qui dit il est pas clair qu'on
peut se fier aux étiquettes d'aliments
du québec
votre réaction roselyne c'est à ce
rapport aujourd'hui du commissaire en
fait c'est vraiment décevant parce que
c'est comme si il ya plein de facettes
lucky qui sont touchés par sa les
producteurs locaux l'éthique
l'environnement l'économie locale
donc en berne jusqu'à un certain point
les citoyens ici vraiment frustrant oui
parce qu'on est pas convaincu de ce
qu'il ya là dedans de ce qu'il ya
derrière aliments du québec toutes les
vérifications ne sont pas faites
robert vous en pensez quoi écoute
aliments du québec a quand même reçu au
cours des trois dernières années ou
quatre dernières années
26 millions au gouvernement pour faire
ce travail leur et on parle de 215
produits de vérifier quand quatre
entreprises en quatre ans inacceptable
moi j'ai trouvé ça honteux
il vous savez j'ai recommencé important
pour moi lâche au québec tu passais ma
vie professionnelle à promouvoir les
fournisseurs québécois qu'un organisme
qui agit avec quotas de co2 avec autant
de faiblesses
moi je j'étais aussi très sucré de la
réponse de la direction de commequiers
de presse de la direction au bruit on va
s'ajuster web un whisky l'argent et je
poserai des questions conseil
d'administration il ya treize personnes
au conseil d'administration en passant
you juste de 20 audrey qui s'ajuste à la
réalité et de la diversité mais qu'est
ce que le conseil d'administration qui
sont les représentants de cette
industrie là on fait avec l'argent
où est l'argent à quoi a servi le mapaq
aliments du québec et le conseil des
appellations réservées manquent à leurs
devoirs de surveillance donc dit
aujourd'hui le commissaire on fait quoi
avec sa rose l'insee mais c'est celle de
se dire exactement qu'est ce qui se
passe parce que moi je m'attendrais plus
à quelles sont les mesures qui sont mis
en place justement pour
vraiment vérifier qu est ce qui se passe
sur le terrain et en même temps les
citoyens on est obligés de leur faire
confiance parce que y'a pas d'autres
mesures en fait pour regarder qu'est ce
qui se passe sur le sur le plancher donc
on y comme à peu pris dans un cul-de-sac
ouais c'est ça comment on peut avoir
confiance robert face à ces produits et
toutes les certifications que nous
voyons lorsque nous allons à l'épicerie
c'est extrêmement compliqué je veux
juste revenir sur la question vous avez
posées aux jeunes c'est parce que moi je
pense que le maroc doit mettre ses
culottes de mal à qui l'on délivre le
ministère de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation du québec a donné 26
millions ils ont un représentant sur le
conseil d'administration qui est là
comme observateurs sont de 26 millions
on doit avoir des gens qui observent le
ps que plus qu observer qui participent
à l'addition parce que revenir à votre
question c'est une préoccupation les
consommateurs surtout avec la pandémie
on a mis beaucoup le panier bleus
l'achat au québec
si les gens sont bernés ou s'ils perdent
confiance c'est avoir un impact sur
l'économie c'est clair et sont les
producteurs locaux probablement la
grande majorité observent les règles
est ce qu'il ya un problème avec
l'industrie alimentaire est ce que
l'industrie alimentaire à sa
responsabilité robert danse à moi j'ai
confiance quand même à l'industrie j'ai
confiance je suis certain que
particulièrement les petits producteurs
locaux à pied des choses il me semble
assez évidente à vérifier le savoir si
le produit vraiment fait au québec où
surtout au niveau de l'agriculture
mais si j'ai peur que la perte de
confiance consommateurs touche
l'économie - tous les revenus des
producteurs
il me suis un peu comme zéro et lancer
si on achète plus de produits à
l'extérieur salle un impact sur
l'environnement avec le transport et la
création de juin
et comment doivent réagir les
consommateurs les gens qui achètent la
vous et moi comment on doit réagir pour
s'assurer que ce qu'on achète et local
et bio est fabriqué au québec rose
l'insee cette situation là je pense ça
va juste continuer le développement plus
rapide peut-être de faire affaire avec
nos producteurs locaux le dos
exploiter le comparer qu'on connaît
c'est ça donc les fermes à proximité qui
distribue des paniers bio ou des paniers
donc où les agriculteurs ou haut niveau
par exemple même si ça peut être un peu
une question une question que les gens
n'aiment pas nécessairement au niveau
des producteurs de viande aussi par
exemple boeuf island ou des trucs comme
ça les gens vont être peut-être plus
portés à savoir d'où proviennent leurs
aliments puis une fois qu'on commence à
faire ce genre de rituel d'avoir
vraiment ses producteurs locaux
on s'habitue rapidement à prendre goût à
quai ce qui ferait que de savoir d'où ce
que ça provient donc peut-être sur des
grandes chaînes d'alimentation il y aura
un impact à long terme mais que comme
son sa soeur aussi le de l'achat local
excellent je vous emmène sur un autre
sujet tout aussi intéressant ce soir qui
est une étude a été publiée aujourd'hui
sur les enjeux économiques en fait ça
vient de la chaire sur les enjeux
économiques inter générationnelle et à
québec ça l'université laval et avec le
cyrano également qui dit qu'il faut
revoir de fond en comble le financement
des soins aux aînés est mise et où
presque tous je vous dirais sur les
soins à domicile sur le principe vous
disent que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
sur le fait qu'ils doivent rester à
domicile ou encore qu'on puisse donner
l'aide à leurs proches pour pouvoir soit
les garder chez eux dans leur maison à
arrou bien dans la maison de leurs
proches
je pense que c'est les plus grands
bénéfices qui peut y avoir pour une
personne en fait d'être la personne âgée
a le choix de la personne voudrait
terminer sa vie parce que moi je regarde
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir ma grand mère
à la maison puis je dirai jamais assez
le lait bénéfique que si les bénéfices
que ça pu avoir sur ma situation puis
mes parents sont d'origine haïtienne n'y
a pas de ch est celle d un actif donc
les grands parents on les garde pas loin
de nous puis sur le même sujet j'ai eu
la chance d'entendre entrevue d'un
soleil proteau qu'un documentaire sur la
dernière maison qui sera diffusé le 6
juin prochain et ce qu'elle avance le c
est quand même des gros chiffres dont au
québec 80 % de la deûle enveloppe qui
est dédié en fait aux soins aux aînés
est dédié à tous
qui institutionnalise est en discussion
se compare par exemple au danemark 73%
de cet argent-là de ce budget là
émissions des soins à domicile je pense
qu'on doit beaucoup à la beaucoup à
apprendre en fait des placements ont
déjà fait leurs preuves
robert vous en pensez quoi moi ce n'est
très sérieuse moi je remets pas en
question mais cinq milieux économiques
les chiffres ne disent pas tout on peut
être très heureux devront pas avoir une
économie de 800 millions de dollars
c'est 10 % du budget c'est ce qui c'est
ce que dit si ce que dit la recherche on
peut on pourrait économiser 1 800
millions avec un conte autonomie en
fonction des besoins de chacun moi il
faut qu'on prouve que ça fonctionne
parce que les chiffres ne disent pas
tout et je vais reprendre un peu sur les
prochains dans un mois dans le texte la
page 29 il dit il est probable que le
maintien à domicile soit alors possible
sans surcharger indûment les proches des
personnes proches aidantes
mais on voit mal trouvé un les projets
danse et déjà au québec c'est une
situation difficile
ça s'améliore pas donc si on apprend le
problème puis on l'envoie dans les
familles
je pense qu'on va se retrouver avec des
problèmes encore plus grand alors ça me
préoccupe moi je prêt à écrire mais je
pense qu'il faut avoir une étude qui
soit plus global
je remets pas en question le dr hébert
quitte à partir d'études étrangers
intrusion qui doit savoir que bien des
choses mais avant d'avoir juste ces
chiffres économiques je le vois aussi si
c'est réalisable et c'est humainement
acceptables pour nos portables
il ya des experts qui disent que le
système actuel s'il n'est pas réformé
faire en sorte que les aînés sont
toujours très vulnérable à une nouvelle
crise comme ce qu'on a connu depuis 14
mois comme la co vide
rosine c est ce que vous partagez ces
inquiétudes là c'est très très
inquiétant faut vraiment tout mettre en
place le pour qu'une telle situation ne
se reproduise plus on se souvient même
notre première vacciner le madame
lévesque la de 89 ans elle avait sa
première dose d le tout de même
contracté l'aco vide le pendant la
pandémie piano certains qui en sont
malheureusement décédées et tout me
semble que si jamais on avait une
nouvelle crise qui est probablement
quelque chose qui va nous arriver
on n'est toujours pas prêt il fera ce
pire
nous faut vraiment qu'on considère nos
aînés d'une autre façon dans certaines
sociétés bce les joyaux ce n'est pas les
femmes et les enfants d'abord donc à
l'afrique qui disent eux mêmes le que
quentin et neymar c'est comme une
bibliothèque qui brûle mais ici on a
perdu une bonne partie de nos archives
il faudrait vraiment prendre soin de
ceux qui sont encore avec nous qui
commença sur le justement le que même
lorsque des générations à venir vont
avoir besoin de ses soins le que tout
soit mis en place aux usa robert en
terminant les scellés les personnes
âgées c'est le parent pauvre du système
de santé
moi je parie que j'ai fait qu'une
expérience avec les options cancer ce
week-end je pense qu'on peut repenser
notre système de santé
on va d'abord définir nos valeurs qui
est le respect de la dignité humaine et
la bienveillance quand on aura repensée
en fonction de ces deux valeurs là je
pense qu'on va avoir un système qui
fonctionne devoir respecter personnes
âgées et toutes les personnes de la
société puisse convaincu d'une chose ça
va coûter moins cher et que ça parfait
merci merci khabar merci roselyne c'est
la semaine prochaine pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit